Quand je suis revenu de l'université, en 1955,
à l'époque de Martin Luther King,
beaucoup de gens sont revenus chez eux à cette époque,
et ont commencé à se disputer avec leurs parents et leurs grands-parents.
Mon père est né en 1885,
et il avait de légers préjugés racistes.
En tant qu'Irlandais, il détestait tellement les Anglais
qu'il ne lui restait plus de sentiments pour personne d'autre.
(Rires)
Mais il avait le sentiment que les noirs étaient inférieurs.
Et quand on disait à nos parents ou à nos grands-parents :
"Qu'est-ce que ça te ferait si tu te réveillais noir demain matin ? "
Ils répondaient : "C'est la chose la plus stupide que je t'aie jamais entendu dire.
Est-ce que tu as déjà entendu parler de quelqu'un qui se soit réveillé le matin...
(Rires)
et qui soit devenu noir ? "
En d'autres termes, ils étaient figés dans les mœurs
et les attitudes pragmatiques dont ils avaient hérité.
Ils ne voulaient pas considérer sérieusement les hypothèses,
et sans hypothèses,
il est très difficile d'élever le débat.
On a besoin de dire : "Imaginez que vous soyez en Iran,
imaginez que tous vos proches
aient souffert des dommages collatéraux,
alors qu'ils n'avaient rien fait de mal.
Qu'est-ce que ça vous ferait ? "
Et si quelqu'un d'une ancienne génération dit :
"Eh bien, notre gouvernement veille sur nous,
c'est à leur gouvernement de veiller sur eux",
c'est seulement qu'il n'est pas prêt à considérer sérieusement l'hypothèse.
Ou prenez un père musulman dont la fille a été violée,
et il pense que son honneur demande qu'il la tue.
Eh bien, il se comporte envers ses mœurs
comme si c'était des rocs dont il aurait hérité,
et qu'on ne pourrait en aucun cas ébranler par des arguments logiques.
Ce ne sont que des mœurs héritées.
Aujourd'hui, nous dirions quelque chose comme :
"Eh bien, imaginez que vous soyez assommé et sodomisé.
Est-ce que vous mériteriez d'être tué ? "
Et il répondrait : "Ça n'est pas dans le Coran.
Ça ne fait pas partie de mes principes."
Aujourd'hui, chacun de vous universalise ses principes.
Vous les énoncez comme des concepts abstraits, et vous leur appliquez les principes de la logique.
Si vous avez un principe comme
"Les gens ne devraient pas souffrir sauf s'ils sont coupables de quelque chose",
alors, pour en exclure les noirs,
il faut faire des exceptions, n'est-ce pas ?
Vous devez dire : "On ne peut pas souffrir
juste parce qu'on a la peau noire.
Ce doit être que les noirs sont coupables d'une manière ou d'une autre."
Ensuite, on peut apporter des preuves empiriques, n'est-ce pas,
et dire : "Comment pouvez-vous considérer tous les noirs comme coupables,
alors que St-Augustin était noir, et que Thomas Sowell est noir."
Et on peut alors élever le débat moral,
parce qu'on ne traite pas les principes moraux comme des entités intangibles.
On les traite comme des universaux,
qui doivent être rendus cohérents sur le plan logique.
Comment en sommes-nous arrivés là en partant des tests de Q.I. ?
Au début, c'est ce qui m'a attiré vers l'histoire cognitive.
Si on regarde les tests de Q.I,
on découvre que certains domaines ont connu de plus grands progrès que d'autres.
Le sous-test de Wechsler sur les similitudes
traite de la classification.
Nous avons fait d'énormes progrès
dans ce sous-test sur la classification.
Il y a d'autres parties des batteries de tests de Q.I.
qui traitent de l'utilisation de la logique sur des concepts abstraits.
Certains d'entre vous ont peut-être essayé les matrices progressives de Raven,
qui fonctionnent par analogie.
En 1900, les gens pouvaient établir des analogies simples.
Par exemple, si on leur disait : "Les chats ressemblent aux lynx.
A quoi ressemblent les chiens ? "
Ils répondraient "Aux loups".
Mais en 1960, les gens pouvaient aborder Raven
à un niveau beaucoup plus sophistiqué.
Si on leur demandait : "On a deux carrés suivis d'un triangle,
qu'est-ce qui vient après deux cercles ? "
Ils pouvaient répondre "Un demi-cercle".
De même qu'un triangle est la moitié d'un carré,
un demi-cercle est la moitié d'un cercle.
En 2010, si on demandait à des étudiants d'université
"Deux cercles suivis d'un demi-cercle,
qu'est-ce qui suit deux 16 ?"
ils répondraient 8, parce que 8 est la moitié de 16.
C'est à dire qu'ils se sont tellement éloignés du monde matériel
qu'ils peuvent même faire abstraction
de l'aspect des symboles qui sont utilisés dans la question.
Cependant, il faut que je dise que tout n'est pas aussi encourageant.
Nous n'avons pas fait de progrès sur tous les fronts.
L'un des moyens qui nous serait bien utile
pour gérer la complexité du monde moderne,
c'est la politique ;
et malheureusement, on a beau avoir des principes moraux,
on a beau classifier, on a beau utiliser la logique sur des concepts abstraits,
si on ne connait pas l'histoire et les autres pays,
on ne peut pas faire de politique.
On a remarqué une tendance chez les jeunes Américains :
ils lisent moins d'histoire, et moins de littérature
et moins de textes parlant de pays étrangers.
Ils sont essentiellement anhistoriques.
Ils vivent dans la bulle du présent.
Ils confondent la Guerre de Corée avec la Guerre du Vietnam.
Ils ne savent pas qui était allié avec l'Amérique pendant la Deuxième Guerre Mondiale.
Pensez à ce que serait l'Amérique
si chaque Américain savait que c'est la cinquième fois
qu'une armée occidentale est allée remettre de l'ordre en Afghanistan,
et s'ils avaient une petite idée de ce qui s'est exactement passé
les quatre dernières fois.
(Rires)
Ce qui s'est passé, c'est qu'ils étaient à peine partis
qu'il n'en restait pas même une trace dans le sable.
Ou bien imaginez comment ce serait
si la plupart des Américains savaient qu'on leur a menti
dans quatre de nos six dernières guerres.
Vous savez, les Espagnols n'ont pas coulé le cuirassé Maine,
le Lusitania n'était pas un navire innocent
mais était chargé de munitions,
les Nord-Vietnamiens n'ont pas attaqué la Septième Flotte,
et, bien sûr, Saddam Hussein détestait Al-Qaïda,
et n'avait rien à voir avec elle,
et pourtant le gouvernement a réussi à convaincre 45 % des gens
qu'ils étaient frères d'armes,
alors qu'il aurait pendu le premier qu'il aurait pu attraper.
Mais je ne veux pas finir sur une note pessimiste.
Le 20ème siècle a montré d'énormes capacités cognitives
chez les gens ordinaires, nous l'avons maintenant compris,
alors que l'aristocratie était convaincue
que les gens ordinaires ne pouvaient pas réussir,
qu'ils ne pourraient jamais partager leur état d'esprit
ou leurs capacités intellectuelles.
Lord Curzon a dit un jour,
il avait vu des gens se baigner dans la Mer du Nord,
et il a dit : "Pourquoi personne ne m'a jamais dit
à quel point les classes inférieures sont blanches de corps ? "
Comme s'ils étaient des reptiles.
Eh bien, Kipling avait raison, et lui avait tort.
Kipling a dit : "L'épouse du colonel et Judy O'Grady
sont sœurs sous leur peau."
(Applaudissements)